who
Oh
[Music]
the city for fun
love
that the whole
lady so high level feed the papa
assalamu alaikum wa rahmatullah wa
better care to brothers and sisters mr.
Borelli Dawa and ensure this is going to
be one of the first series of many that
are about today I'm going to put forth
in sha Allah in the coming months
because obviously we do a lot of videos
regarding you know a lot of interviews
social experiments obviously I wanted to
do a bit of face to come videos and deal
with matters that certain youth go
through them as a whole some certain
stuff that we need to work on both
myself and you guys obviously and I
thought these videos we've really
beneficial we can go through certain
topics and today's topic is going to be
about judging judging other people now
bronze says when it comes to the matter
of judging is is I've seen it a lot I've
seen it since I've come to Islam I've
seen it left right center I've seen
mainly before I used to think those who
are practicing the Deen will look down
on those that don't I you think this is
not and this is one of the common
problems to be honest in in general this
is the mainly the case but all but I
have come to realize that there is
individuals that do not practice the
Deen and they do judge those who do that
for example if a brother grows a beard
they like all your a Mufti now and all
these kind of behaviors and we do have
other examples or for example sisters
that deserve the hijab and a bio they
look down on those who do not observe
the hijab and think oh she's this is
that and those who do not wear the hijab
they look at them and say oh she thinks
she's pious or whatever so we always
jump to these assumptions and we start
judging individuals and this is not
really really nice because when I first
came to Islam I personally witnessed
this myself you know the brothers that I
used to hang around with they would
really like stick it on me with certain
errors mistakes that I would do and they
would have no patience and what lie this
is really sad we need to understand
something and if you have friends that
are new to the Dean if they're
practicing please send us this video to
them it would really beneficial
inshallah if you have a friend that's
come to the Dean you have to be patient
don't jump and just start judging them
on the mistakes that they do if they
come to the deal like for example you're
saying that we seen a Masjid can you
imagine somebody with tattoos
who's got I don't know a Mohican hair a
blond Mohican hair it's got tattoos
everywhere pierced his buddies
Pearsall / he comes into the Masjid what
what would you eat as Muslims do the
first thing that we would do is what the
hell is he doing here would we ever
think to herself hold on a second before
I start judging before I start jumping
to assumptions let me see maybe he's
interested in Islam would we do that
we don't know most of us would not do
this and this is the reason why it's so
important because you can put that
person off if your conversation what you
doing here oh this is this is not a
nightclub what what do you think that
individuals going to think you sit him
down and talk to him and this happens
with the youth Israel when soon you've
come to the Masjid or they want to do a
u-turn they're coming with an earring
what do you do automatically judge
automatically go and the first thing we
speak to him about or actually you know
your earring hold it
calm down for a second speak to him it's
a gradual process and you need to
understand something my dear brothers
and sisters just because you're
practicing the Deen just because I lost
want Allah says in the Quran in surah
taha verse 7 and he found you lost and
he guided you now ponder upon this verse
he guided you he found you lost and
you're out there judging did you guide
yourself did you want they say you know
what yes I've just got this revelation
or whatever and I'm just like yes no you
almost want Allah saying he found you
lost and he guided you you as individual
I'm speaking to you you was the party
animal couple of months ago you was the
one who do all kinds of stuff and now
that a las montañas guided you and
you're practicing 100 you're trying your
best and you're looking down on others
because of their little petty mistakes
whatever it may be we know in Islam the
Prophet Muhammad sallallahu wasallam
said the Dinah's advice yes we need to
advise our brothers and sisters hundred
percent
nobody's say nothing against that and
those individuals who say or for example
only god can judge me don't judge me
that's another aspect it's a fine line
you know I might talk about this in my
figure this contradict him so he's
saying don't judge others about then
again you know people can't say don't
judge me there's a fine line because you
need to understand prophecy
this is that when you're judging someone
for example if I'm walking and I see a
brother in a fog
kissing a girl I instantaneously inside
me I'm like that's wrong I've judged
about how I've said okay I've understood
that what he's doing is wrong
now me approaching him is the part where
I have to not like with my speech
judging how I go to him and just advise
him a kebab and say look a key what I
think like you know you shouldn't do
this or whatever it may be talk to him
in the best of ways but if you go up
them say a key around what the hell are
you doing and go into this madness it's
not going to work that individual is not
going to understand another thing that I
want to mention brothers and sisters is
basically just put yourself in a
situation like just imagine the person
that you're judging right the person
that you're judging what if they're
going through a family problem what if
they have lost their father worth they
have lost their mother what if they
don't even have both their parents why
if there is something like you need to
understand just the way you want to go
paradise they want to go paradise - you
can't figure stuff you know okay I'm the
only one and obviously our guidance come
from Alice ponds are the best I must we
know that but just imagine for a second
you are judging that individual you
don't even know what is their
circumstance what are they going through
you don't know and you're judging them
and putting so much more pressure on
them that they're saying you know what
forget you guys
you know Islam I don't even want that
anymore you are going to be the reason
that you have put off someone one lifee
Allah you really need to feel lost want
Allah when you're dealing with certain
people in certain matters be very
careful because they could be going
through God knows what you don't know
what they're going through and this does
not mean that's any excuse that okay
just cause you're going through that and
you just go and do all kinds of stuff no
but we need to understand we need to say
you know what when we look at assist if
I look at a sister with non nor hey job
or the way stress and yes it's
inappropriate but I should hate the sin
not the individual we should not do that
we should not hate individual but try to
advise that even if you see a brother
that's doing wrong they start one lie
I'm telling you I've been in the dowel
scene brothers around me have been in
this do and their witness to that when
you come across somebody and even though
they come in that scene and in their
height and in their head they are
thinking or he's going to judge me but
when you go up to them and say at least
allow a little or sister for you another
sister you got another sister has a
wedded job Selam aleykum sister when you
go up to him and approach them in that
manner without judging them I think
actually how you doing this day while
where I speak them in a gentle manner
buy them a cup of coffee drink water
food come sit down actually let's talk
what Allah he will meet with their heart
it will melt their heart and this will
help them and and feel more connected be
like wow like he's not judging me or
she's not judging me from the way I'm
dressed and you encouraging them while
like you're rewarded wallah you need to
understand we need to be understanding
and I go back to the point once again
who guided you did you guide yourself
I lost wanted has guided you my dear
brothers and sisters one lie be careful
before I lost want Allah as a punishment
takes it away from you you need to
understand and what lie please do not
look down on other people try your best
your friend your neighbor your work
colleague your your friend at school at
college university wherever it may be
try your best to advise them and also
brothers and sisters one or one other
point that I want to make is sometimes
as like I'm in the Dawa brothers that I
know brothers attended our sometimes we
even fall for this behavior of we're not
actually given doubted individual what
we're giving dower to our judgment what
how do we do this for example we open
the TV MC logic Richard Dawkins right
and we see him and his behavior as an
individual and we're like okay that's it
in our head were thinking every single
atheist is like that so when we're
giving dowel to an atheist in our head
before we have even started and he said
oh I'm an atheist were like oh okay it's
automatically starting the judgment how
well like okay yeah is that that's what
do we do we just go straight in and
refuting him or going in these kind of
in this behavior but we shouldn't do
that because us doing that is exactly
what they're doing to us today the media
what are they doing every single Muslim
is they say they're all the same so when
we say like how would we feel if you
went to an individual said I'm a Muslim
and I go oh oh you're a terrorist and
like so how would we feel we would not
like it because you need to understand
that you're Stein to judge I want to go
to put on Quran surah nisa chapter 94
who else wanted
o you who have believed when you go
forth in the way of your Lord
investigate and do not say to the one
who gives you a greeting of peace you
are not a believer so you need to
understand before judging two
assumptions you know we have a lot of
people you know just they may hear
something oh this dis dis brother his
Aikido is like this or like that oh
really
Oh next time you see him you don't even
give Salaam have you investigated a
matter have you looked into the matter
have you spoken to the brother no I've
heard it I've heard it from a friend
no you're judging learn the matter
investigate like a lost want Allah says
in the Quran first understand the matter
look into it and then come to your
decision of whatever however you want to
act also the Prophet Muhammad sallallahu
wasallam be used to make du'a to Allah
sponsor and say oh the one who turns
hard keep my heart on your religion and
also we know your remedy Salaam used to
make du'a to Allah sponsor and say all a
divert me from worshiping idols so what
do we learn from that the best man to
work the best man to walk this planet
the prophets who have even themselves
their making towards Allah so Allah and
not only that if we go to surah al-imran
verse 9 so it verse 8 it says our Lord
like this is this is this is how we
should be our Lord let not our hearts
deviate after we you have guided us and
grant us from yours yourself mercy
indeed you are the beasts or so we
should have this mentality of we should
extract and learn something from this
that you are not guaranteed when you
come and practice the Deen don't ever
think to yourself oh yes
that's it me I've time a bit I'm on the
Dean now a lot I don't need to worry
about nothing if the profits if the
profits always made do a las once a lot
to keep on the straight path then who
are you to think to yourself yes you
know I'm perfect you know I see a few
individuals who are not practicing and I
start pinpointing and judge and judging
them one lie this is not the
characteristics or believe it's not we
should we should we should have this
understanding and this is where a man is
play hero and share this with your
friends each other if you guys benefited
and I'm gonna have more serious is that
this coming up in sha allah assalamu
alayka wa rahmatullah wa barakato
let's crack it I'm using it amuses
declaration in the back okay whatever
you do it what pictures I'll find you
gone to Instagram check maybe there's
some good ones okay go go okay let me
get that away from time do do not come